اذا ننوه للخبر العاجل الان وصول الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اذا هذا هو الخبر العاجل الان على شاشه
الجزيره وهو هناك زياره مجدوله اعلن عنها
للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى بولندا لكنه
هذه هي الزياره لم تكن معلنه زياره اذا
الرئيس الامريكي يصل الى العاصمه
الاوكرانيه قبل ايام من او في ذكرى الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا مرور عام اذا ذكرى
مرور عام على الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
والرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يزور العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف سنبقى في متابعه هذا
الخبر العاجل اذا الرئيس الامريكي في
زياره غير معلن عنها كان من المفترض ان ي
بولندا الا ان هذا الخبر العاجل الان على
شاشه الجزيره يضر ان الرئيس الامريكي قرر
زياره كييف سنتابع بطبيعه الحال السياقات
التي تاتي فيها هذه الزياره الرئيس
الامريكي منذ فتره طويله يعلن الدعم
المتواصل
حرب الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ايضا هناك
اجتماعات تتعلق بالدعم في المفوضيه
الاوروبيه وفرض عقوبات جديده على روسيا
سوف نحاول ان نفهم سياقات هذه الزياره في
ظل التطورات الاخيره في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ميدانيا وايضا على الصعيد
السياسي نذكر اذا مراسله الجزيره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن زار الجدار التذكاري
لقتل الحرب في ساحه القديس ميخائيل في
كييف اذا هذه الزياره غير المجدوله غير
المعلن عنها في توقيت حرج بالنسبه للحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وفي ظل الذكرى
الاولى بعد مرور عام كامل على هذه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا بطبيعه الحال هناك
عده سياقات تاتي في هذه الزياره منها
الدعم الامريكي المستمر رغم ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قدمت عدد كبير من
الاسلحه
مؤخرا ايضا وعدت
باستمرار هذا الدعم واكدت عليه ايضا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع شركائها
الاوروبيين تبحث عدد من العقوبات الجديده
التي يفترض انها تفرض على الجانب الروسي
بعد مرور عام على العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا اذا نذكر بالخبر
العاجل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم
عاصمه اوكرانيا بعد ان كان من المفترض ان
يزور بولندا اولا هي زياره بطبيعه الحال
لها دلالاتها في سياقات معينه
لا يمكن اغفال موضوع مرور عام على هذه
الحرب والدعم الامريكي
المستمر لاوكرانيا هذه الصور الاولى
تاتينا الان من هذه الصوره الاولى لزياره
الرئيس الامريكيين نلاحظ فيها
تواجد عدد كبير من قوات الحمايه وايضا
الجنود
لاول زياره للرئيس الامريكي الى العاصمه
كييف هذه صور مباشره تاتينا الان
هذه صور التقطت قبل قليل وكما ذكرنا ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن زار الجدار
التذكاري لقتل الحرب الذي يشاهد الان في
خلفيه الصوره اذا هذا هو الجدار التذكاري
لقتل الحرف في ساحه القديس ميخائيل في
كييف
هذه الصور اذا المتاحه حتى الان التقطت
قبل قليل للرئيس الامريكي في كييف عاصمه
اوكرانيا
بطبيعه الحال نتوقع ان يكون هناك مؤتمر
صحفي للرئيس الامريكي مع
الرئيس الاوكراني
اذا هذه الصور كما ذكرنا هي للجدار
التذكاري لقتل الحرب في ساحه القديس
ميخائيل في كييف والتي زارها الرئيس
الامريكي اذا هذه الزياره ربما اذا اردنا
ان نفهم اسياخ الذي جاءت فيه لم يعلن عنها
مسبقا وهو ربما هو ليس امرا
معتادا لكن يمكن ان يفهم نظرا للنواحي
الامنيه لم يعلن عن جدوله هذه الرحله لكن
الرئيس الامريكي الان ومن خلال هذه الصور
موجود في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
بطبيعه الحال كما ذكرنا هي مرحله حساسه في
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا مع عدم وجود اي
افق لحل سياسي رغم المحاولات التي
والدعوات التي كانت في هذا السياق